can I ask you a question what where's
your whoop my whoop
yeah my womb where's your whoop I worked
this morning I didn't charge it decided
to leave it on the charger but you can
charge it you can charge on the go but
it's five days I don't want to distract
the viewers I didn't want it's five days
five days to do it I hiked I hiked on
Friday yeah eight miles yeah [ __ ] my
pants even calculated that yeah
everything I'm a mouse tells you how far
you go you pee on so as you're hiking
you're whoop will tell you how to tell
me am i exact my heart rate humming it
also tells you mile is a mile oh yeah
everything dude I'm telling you there's
nothing there's not another tracker on
the planet that's as detailed and has
multiple kind of functions heart rate
rest output everything it's got that
Bluetooth Low Energy everything dude it
connects with third-party devices yep
connect someone it's got the software
improvements it's got the strain coach
gives you training level recommendations
based on your bodies recover it banzz
it's got snap plus overlay live hard
calories live strain in real time with
your phone uses videos to analyze your
performance or share with a coach or on
social media I'm telling you man there's
nothing like it
Wow you rock it you find out you get all
your output it what what now now can I
get a little promo here can I get a
little bit what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
say be $30 okay you go to whoop whoop
has provided the tea fat Kate are me
listeners $30 off their purchased with
the code fighter just go to whoop calm
Tommy WH o Opie dot-com use the code
fighter at checkout safe $30 and
optimize the way you train again that's
fighter
whoop comm promote fighter I like it and
a chin is Fanning fit my son's name is
Finn but I think my son do chin have you
been chanting Finn and my chin just said
I like when you go cuz you know I'm
gonna talk [ __ ] I love it Brian's where
you talk [ __ ] because I lost are you
Scott you know what else we do in can I
be honest whenever one of us go can I be
honest and wanting to to each other
that's when he gets the best
renin and i i think it's safe to say
that you and i like we will tell each
other the secret of the secret it's oh
you know when you know good fellows when
they're on the getting their hair done
their own black guys and shake it from
their from their husbands yeah that's us
we're not the good fellas Oh will the
wives get our nails done so sat beside
your brother if you really needed to
hide a body or not you're my throttle I
think so right Jase too far I really am
probably your first call my only because
I'm um I'm a I'm your soldier yes right
the only toe and it's so funny how
nobody else I'll get it tick I got a
text from you sometimes and I'll just
get this whoo I got some juicy info but
not for your ears yeah and the only time
the only time I ever called Rennick was
we never talked about the phone cuz what
guys stop for a living I'll [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] I'll call him and then he doesn't
answer I'll call him again I will dude
what's going on no you go talk to you
everything all right talk to me and the
best is when you hit me with this when
you go you go
I got info but only only for your ears
in person that's double secret [ __ ] man
I need to know now little [ __ ] tease for
yeah like jump in look at the teal yep
yep I got new hey did you see chin
playing the guitar did you do it on
Instagram dude you don't probably
doesn't see anything I do oh yeah I do
cuz I follow you really you were
strumming of course oh I don't know you
could play the guitar you were strumming
oh you can play like that yeah I had no
idea I would bring that [ __ ] up yeah
[ __ ] love to be able to play the
guitar that oh do I win it's off but
firstly the peer map yeah no more than
that no way get targets the chicks must
see this [ __ ] hit this [ __ ] kid let me
turn the audio up a little yeah turn
that [ __ ] a little country for bed
let's see you Dave Matthews
you can jam on a guitar look at me I'm
alright song sucks
you are so good you're really good thank
you
why do you sing these boring spunk
though this is a classic Tom like a
Montgomery
I like the way you're planning I love it
slide down the other rift or what's it
called the wrath of fret yeah frets
string it up babe
[ __ ] red city let's help you and I
because we don't know guitar you're
streaming up shred city shred stations
been working out to have you followed no
I have no I haven't seen you know
there's what stories are what no I but
because Brian number last week I think
was last week or week yeah I even told
cat this Brian goes I give ya that and
you go I give people advice all the time
but they just don't take it yeah that
was like a dagger and I was like okay
I'm gonna definitely go now his advice
he just to work out he said he wants to
pay for my training
he's here to pay for my training I paid
for it good just take a class would you
do it I mean this one that's you afraid
I like couch is different but yeah it's
too far yeah downtown's has to be yeah
house we convenience but it's really
hard to find gyms in LA I decide to get
my body moving first and then I'll take
you up on the offer
but there's a shitload of gyms in
downtown downtown does it fit for me my
favorite is the on it that that on it
half hour workout that we would do when
we're in Austin if I could find that I'd
be meet a cold if I already do that
every damn if it was like across the
street
yes I'm sick of working I'm [ __ ] I am
sick of it I am too I put on music I put
on you to out to my favorite shows I got
my dead layer so you can you know bike
right my bike all the time
dude I I've been biking lately that's so
tiring me I fight this but your body dad
so now like I can go 30 miles my bicycle
chases but now I hiked on Friday
I did eight miles in Santa Monica I
wanted the Canyon Santa Monica I did
eight my house at Shin the woods
fish meat as blunt its policy told me
about this and I'd like to I'd like to
hear this I'd like to talk about this
well I have been really cute over you
with anybody
nope okay you realize really ketogenic
yeah I've been on keto diet yeah I drank
a ton of coffee and I got up early to
drive down there sure I dropped that
morning poo
not that morning you know I'm saying a
crop morning pay problem a tripoli so I
had stand up the night and horror
Thursday night I thought yeah but I came
home wife he had to pull a for me
waiting oh so it's a it's twelve nine
it's 12:30 sir a huge pin usually I
don't eat then but in a lot of hot
sauce is all kiito's just chicken
guacamole you know you got a [ __ ] now
it's like that went to sleep
Papa Matt sleep yeah Pub wakes up right
I don't know let's say six cups of
coffee before I go that's good that's
good
I'm halfway through this hike some fans
recognize me I'll make sure yeah no
problem hmm tell me hits and I go oh my
god I have to try well this hurts yeah
and I'm gonna power through this cuz you
guys are behind me so I'm parents are
trying to show I'm a leader you know I'm
[ __ ] going sweat Maya it's hot I'm
sweating two miles in it's hurting so
bad I do I can't I'm telling you I grab
a tree like this the guys go you are I
brought you I'm good and I'm cramping a
little dehydrate ever up you get you
boys go ahead I gotta go ahead
they wanna head Scout on top of that
mountain yeah I don't see anyone come
for a little while in a while but they
are coming yeah I have to drop trou
right there dude can you squat or do you
not know how to squat no I squat you
thought you taught me that many moons
ago yeah I squatted
yeah but I went in I went into Jumanji
now I gotta go ahead go now wait peer
deep in the hood and where I'm like oh
it's for sure my little red riding-hood
got lost I'm talking snakes whatever
them but it's worth it cuz if I don't
release this inner ol in me I'm gonna
die yeah I spray-painted that entire
tree Brown you could throw that tree
away you throw it away so here's the
thing animals avoid that for the next
week his thing
I don't know poison ivy I'm not an
expert so I'm like I'm not wipe my ass
with these leaves no so I keep it going
oh yeah mud button so I keep it going
that's moving has every lady follower
but whatever could you would but I got
my butt so I'm still going you gotta
take your underwear off or your and use
your shirt or something I thought about
that it's war you know me I'm
self-consciously my shirt on rather have
my butt so I keep going get body
dysmorphic yeah so I keep going right
another mile old doctor diarrhea hits
again going nah we ain't done bro yep
now uh the I hear a guy go there's a
waterfall down there I go how much on
this waterfall and [ __ ] all over yeah
and they're just wash my shirt that's
where I'm at right now we're just
waiting your ass I've seen Bear Grylls
yeah I've seen survivor man I'm on that
level yeah no yeah so I'm like perfect
so I I'm mentally I'm like just keep it
tight to get that waterfall
[ __ ] everywhere dude the thing it's
turtle and you got it the whole time you
got I can't walk around with it with a
dirty whistle dude I can't do it I'm
smut sweat I'm sweating and you got
Putin and I got short Reebok I'm thought
oh you got shorts on yeah yeah yeah so
I'm Kim it time you've been staying them
up here stayed them up I'm just trying
to you this waterfall your boy gets the
waterfall that's [ __ ] Navy SEAL mental
toughness I get to the waterfall what do
you think happened everybody's there no
no one's there there's no water it's a
dry water field you know I've we're in
Los Angeles hasn't rain there's a bigger
thing not gonna work now there's still
some kids on the to board ever like
swing from like all right uh-huh
so I went behind the tree again and
[ __ ] painted it brown oh boy
then I hit the road and then so you
walked all the way back with with a with
a miles a miles with your poor [ __ ]
your poor whistle must be of all kinds
of irritated I was fine take a look at
it all right pick a spot on the wall
let's peel that peach and see what's
going on dude what a disaster late night
Chipotle ketogenic diet you mix that
with a little coffee my son my son
always walks around with my butt I don't
know what he's doing that's what kids do
that drives me crazy oh my hey bro
you'll be naked sits on my lap I'm like
well you know I can smell you
you smell like a what's going on it's
just you got this run like you got it
can you play with your mind no no he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he doesn't give off
kids eight-year-old boys dirty you got
it you gotta wait to selling clowns on
there like oh [ __ ] I clean I whistle but
boys don't give off not not to take an
action at least I give me God I know I
didn't show no not till a certain sort
kids start making fun of how about my
kid I'm such a pushover with my band
whatever you want
and I was trying I'm like you know I'm
gonna chill I'm like an environmental
thing that he wants i'ma chill and then
we're in a store and he's wanted this
this dinosaur but he and I'm like we
can't do like let's just would listen if
you clean you know I'm trying to go if
you work out but I usually give him a
surprise he works out with me every
morning I'm like yo put five days in and
then I'll get you this you go pop I want
the Dyson or call it Dyson or and it's
so cute let's get that Dyson oh that's
so cute
he was my papa and I'm like
it's not happening he's like throwing a
little fare when it's not happening dude
you know I just bought your toy last
week let's get to the truck if you work
out pop of five days in a row we'll come
back and get that I turn around he looks
like puss from [ __ ] oh I want the
Dyson orally huh I say Dyson or that's
so [ __ ] cute grab the Dyson or
quickly hi I'll tell your mom quickly I
know I got that Dyson you can't help it
Dyson why would I like to because I cut
by his he's European Papa but Papa
yeah that's great he was a Papa papa so
he'll be the only kid in America that
cause his dad Papa which is fantastic
and said about a bro bilingual Papa come
Adam um now he's gonna be giant he's
gonna be a charm Adam bro yeah no big
three-year-old earth
oh my son used to do my side opposed by
I post my son I don't mean Erik you be
my son can do ten push-ups
three and a half is that true ten
push-ups raizy
ten push oh that's crazy that's crazy
sees me doing it and then another day he
gets down animatics what are you doing
now I went holy [ __ ] I missed I went
holy [ __ ] he's doing pushing I don't
want to make it a big done one who think
he's different like you know but it is
different but he is dice dice when he
was like about that agent maybe he was
like forcing because it's ridiculous
ridiculous metal you know what it man he
goes it's ridiculous so cute I was like
hey I'll bite his face get me a muzzle
now I'll bite this [ __ ] kisser and
his head he's just woken up her nap he's
all sweaty and his head was off I was
like I'll bite your face dude oh my god
ask for a Rolex we called the Rolex a
Dyson North he'd be wearing a Rolex
right now I'm down like whatever you
want yeah Greg that's the cutest thing
in the world oh I went grab that [ __ ]
Dyson or right now
Oh God is cute man and his dad should
his pants the next day so there's that
I've done that I was walking my dude
it's embarrassing yeah I had curry while
you were hiking I was I'd eaten Korean
food thank you what yep Eduardo Atwater
which is very good
cats fully discussed it now yeah and I I
was walking my dog and I decided I was
gonna go I could take my morning poo now
I'm gonna walk my dog now I write when I
walk and I know you do probably saying
that's why I hiked up the fly run so I
that's how I write so I'm walking the
dog and I'm down the block now this is
Venice and I'm and I go a little further
because I hear the rumbling so you're in
a boat if you're a little rowboat and
you see clouds and you're like but the
fish are just a little bit
I want to cast my rocket there I can
beat the storm because I'll just wrote
but storms rolling quick bro yeah before
you know what those waves are six seven
eight feet you're in a [ __ ] you're
deep you're in too deep bro and you're
gonna try to turn back now you got the
[ __ ] sweats
oh man so I I [ __ ] well I turn I turn
too late and it's too late and I'm
telling you dude I was walking
stiff-legged I was walking stuck I
couldn't [ __ ] on the side dude there's
nothing like it in the world there's I'm
walking stiff-legged I break into this
my side thing and I [ __ ] I've told a
story I should be in the in the side of
the house and it became a disaster we
through the house way um here's the
thing dude there's nothing I I think
I've told her my mom same way when I was
a kid I was gonna work with my mom I
remember my mom had to [ __ ] so bad she
hopped the curb parked illegally in
front of this mall left me in the car
and just ran off and that's amazing
20 minutes later cops around the car
like what the [ __ ] you're seven this is
a little I'll talk but same thing on
being in the middle of the ocean I just
had a memory I went to Alaska with my
father and we were in a what's it called
a speedboat you know the kind of bored
with the outboard motor wheels yeah yeah
and we were going to a house boat where
it was a makeshift restaurant run by
this awesome dude named sweet Eklund
I'll never forget yeah
and so we're going in the storm kicks up
and I don't know how to I'm not a seaman
my dad ain't either but he was a marine
and heeds he knows how to do boats and
he [ __ ] starts getting super nervous
because the water starts to little
choppy
well we're hitting waves like doosh
showers
oh I'm 33 sir my friend
well well no life that thun shuttle
grown man here's the problems I didn't
realize I couldn't stand what my dad was
getting really nervous and telling me to
sit in the back and and he was like
getting serious because I was [ __ ]
around cuz the way is really big and he
said but we made it to the boats but it
got really really scary we kind of just
made it the storm kicked up and I was
amazed at how fast those ways how heavy
those waves were in this little boat so
I got I actually we actually got it was
very dicey and scary we were fine got
there no problem but then the waves
really kicked up and he looked out and
he said in the big boat imagine getting
caught out there now game over and I
said I said [ __ ] those waves kick that
but he goes yep you have no idea why he
was there no he was nervous because you
can't swim you can't fall in that water
it's the North Atlantic ice cold it's
way colder than you think
it's it's you you die in ten minutes you
go into hypothermia with an exposure
suit even in the summer and it was like
I think it was like just spring we were
we were I think was spring break
I can't member I had a player pop was so
nervous dude you know Marie Marie Marie
hey Marie he knows Umberto I didn't
realize that that water is you get in
the water and it's a cold I didn't
realize I thought it was just water do
well in the cold daddy doesn't do well I
call that all had you dead load well
Papa does well because I look like
Frankenstein he's got no neck he's
supposed her
but even that not keel Franklin's you
know humans are not no humans are not
humans are not filled now in fact I get
really mad at him eating he was eating
he's golfing his age but eating terribly
I'm like you can't eat waffles and he
can't see well it makes me us what they
do it makes me angry you're eating
waffles and before that you had you had
cereal it's old they just have no idea
not my design levels you're eating sugar
my girl's stepdad Steve who I love but
every more except and we have that it's
a coffee creamer blitz like french
vanilla
yeah great if you mean toffee mate I
went you're eating seven snicker bars
before even Wow try to cry go look at
the sugar level dude lose weight you
can't talk I say gotta lose weight
because when my son comes in November
you don't be the fat grandpa yeah oh
what's that don't you
a bunch of melon a bunch of fruit I'm
eating I don't drink your orange juice
and having special cases I'll think
about it
that's that spikes your insulin it's all
sugar I go cause you that's a boy Adam
the after Adam yeah you know what trauma
was last name I'm handsome dude and I'm
ray no no not the comic Adam but he's
unlike CSI the actor come on Adam
Rodriguez Adam Rodriguez I was in Venice
yesterday doing a photo shoot right and
I'm at I love them I'm at Jelena I'm at
Jelena with beer and my girl were
sitting there she's such a time peace
he's section all hold on Adam Rodriguez
comes in with his wife who's up she's
another she said she's a 10 she's my
beautiful little she's the female
version of him he's just a whole lot one
of my favorite piece there are [ __ ]
kids their two daughters things on the
planet they came in dude it shut the
restaurant Danna these two little girls
I think once two and a half yeah
and the other was five I've never seen
the cutest yeah cleans worse it's why
the greatest creatures I've ever seen
yeah they're ridiculous oh my god and he
is years oh well he's just a better
person than you and I you know that
right in every way a better pretty facet
I love that [ __ ] I spend time
with him I leave every time I get to
hang with him it's a it's a treat great
dude oh he's not always working - oh he
never stops working what he's such a
good-looking person and his wife came
out [ __ ] is that
yeah that's Adam Rodriguez right there
look at him we gotta get him on the
podcast cuz he's [ __ ] hilarious on him
got some tits on dude you missed two and
a half-year-old was speaking like he was
a TEDTalk
the [ __ ] happening here yeah the whole
thing is well their life or their
beautiful family they're just a
ridiculous hold on the best-looking
family he was with when he met his wife
he was with this this like miss you know
I don't know Miss Venezuela or something
beautiful and he saw her across the room
and everything stopped he goes dude he
is I was just like that's the most that
that's it that's my girl watch a nice
human being
yeah and smart hombre and Chinese and
stuff oh my god
he's got it all going dude hey man take
it easy bro man you're lingering on him
No
leave it chin no no no yeah he's the
best
yeah it's oh my god it's steel both his
daughters they're so cute it's crazy
oh very strange yeah before we're on
this I had a I had a thought
I'm trying thinking what the hell it was
it was interesting I know I was gonna
ask you Kat do you and your do you and
your man talk about like the way we talk
about like [ __ ] your pants and stuff
pray not huh yes absolutely
really he's been well since she was 10
yeah basically I Billy Joe Joanna for a
long-ass tongue we don't know nothing
I've never farted in front of really
know any woman I'm with will discuss
must see me poo yeah how's that working
on anyway do I [ __ ] paint the walls
yeah oh fourtner Hey yeah well ago man
listen man's like oh you're disgusting
and I don't I keep it super sexy we have
a spray way with the poo poo pourri
yeah well did you hear I have you're a
discipline man gallons of pooper you're
a discipline man it makes sense like
your your your your wife is your girl is
so like every detail in that house is
it's crazy her dislike Johanna games
remaining in parents she's like Martha
Stewart she's like that she like these
were like Martha's hot my heart though
when she Martin when where the Stewart
was young though she was very good look
dude [ __ ] off on the cheek slightly
dude right now she was always the other
one he set aside some old labor men last
week and we brought them should they
have [ __ ] dragon well oh with
somebody's wife no Connie Aaron
Spelling's wife yeah yeah bring her out
when she was young she was a good good
gorgeous goddamn well he was no dude she
was something else I promise you Joe
right dude just good there she would she
look take your mouth I saw a video that
would take like your mum I'm into my mom
you're saying though you and your man
talk like that yeah I I don't think like
he'll walking like baby I gotta take a
[ __ ]
yeah he'll say that but he isn't
comfortable as long as I'm
not in the vicinity he's really weird
about if because we have one bathroom in
our apartment so sometimes I need to go
and I need to grab Sun from the bathroom
if he's pooping he's so uncomfortable if
I walk in but I want to walk in so badly
because he says he doesn't want me in
there yep yep i I want to be in there
when he is Lucy oh wait hold on I want
nothing a girls have this weird thing
where they I think it's because men are
vulnerable
yes and so you guys want to like so I'll
do this oh you'll do that I've had
girlfriends where I've been like
whatever you do I've said it but my mark
my wife I'm like whatever you do do not
come in here and look and then I'm in
there no then they can tweak the door
and they're like there's like get out
there can't help it oh you're the time
together - foghorn your girl yes
interesting what about you to know that
I'm any also but just not my girl not
any girl I've ever did anything right
never dude never yeah you have a never
thing about poof it's just not sexy man
of course it's not sexy it's disgusting
yeah it's this is that for the broad but
there's something about girls that do
where they're just like they want to
know or something I don't think so no
good girl she peeks in they want to see
you vulnerable sitting there like a
you're not like Babe can you rip a big
fart for me
no I think it's the vulnerability thing
yeah I get all I like being able to be
in those situations where I know he's at
his most vulnerable and is uncomfortable
interesting yeah it's like it's like a
safety circle yeah dude the one thing I
was driving to it's a certainty you have
your red buttons if I'm taking a [ __ ] do
not talk to me do not talk to me do not
bother me with anything it's all it you
know people have certain tree yeah yeah
yeah that will trigger the [ __ ]
really or and this is trigger me it
happened the other day my dad was in
town I remember my dad cooked dinner a
bike dinner's ready
you know and you'd like you're finishing
something up and then my dad will come
down I do that and that used to drive me
enough my dad was over to my house
making dinner and goes I was doing
something goes hey brand dinners are you
all right cool he goes hey let's go
it's hot like oh my house pop oh you're
my house Papa Oh sometimes my mother
will my mother I got really mad this
weekend I got really mad this week it's
like my mom I love my mom but I got
actually inappropriately angry really
what you do well so there are couple
things my mother will do one is she
wants me about danger she'll find danger
everywhere but also this is there's
always this to watch order order a
sandwich what's this it's or in the
afternoon I'll take the chicken oh you
know we're eating in lesson three our
pine oh my god oh you I'm fifty two
excuse me I know what I need but that's
a true thing from when you were a kid
yeah then where does never ever go away
yeah but so so they never I don't know
how you make people look like I'm mad
about effort this is what I got mad
about when you are in Park City and your
parents live up on a hill hashtag money
you you have to drive up a road now now
there are it's a rural area so there are
deer everywhere I've never I've never
driven that route wherever you're
driving 30 miles an hour I've never
driven that route with my mother where
she hasn't said slow down you could hit
a deer and most importantly you might
hit a moose and you know you'll die if
you hit a moose but you can sue I know
but I let's never happen have you never
happened and have you ever been even
close look dude there is two moose there
are two moons all of you talk in that
area but in all of you get on the
mountain yeah I guess they've seen some
moose twice there too that they know of
that there too those must have never
been hit by a [ __ ] car you know why
cuz moose hear a car and they get away
but apparently sometimes you'll see the
Moose can't hit there they're not gonna
make a moose yeah and I'm going 30 or 25
miles an hour their size of a bus I got
it yeah there's that bus I got it
so yelled it I'm not kidding every time
I'm not kidding she goes be careful of
the moose now my daughter's in the car
my daughter was my caddy all weekend
wonderful weekend my daughter my
daughter my mother would be careful if
you could hit it we're talking about
[ __ ] something interesting I camera
was ya know is actually about Winston
Churchill on how terrible his childhood
and it was really interesting because he
was sure but we interrupted with the she
goes be careful of the Moose you could
hit a moose and you know they're black
you don't see them until it's too late I
do see them and I'm not gonna be careful
of a moose because I'm driving 20 miles
and we're talking middle hey my middle
of the day I was in my my daughter
daughter goes daddy be careful of the
moose now she's afraid and my mother
goes because it can kill you they come
right through and say I don't kill you
yeah my daughter's she doesn't know she
goes Danny be careful and I'm like yeah
I'm not gonna be careful I'm daddy be
careful she was you should be careful
you're being stubborn I go I'm gonna
speed up now well now I find out the way
to beat up the 51 year old man pi not
the way to deal with 52 and I and I it's
trigger house trying to help you I know
and I'm 31 and I go mmm
daddy starts to cry and I go stop crying
I'm not gonna hit a moose nobody's gonna
die from moose my mother oh you're an
ill-tempered you're an Intel tempered
Bratton this is exactly how you're the
moose I go I'm not gonna in a mouse she
called you breath I got I got a quarter
mile to go and I'm not gonna miss the
chance anyone I'm freaking out how far
is it
it's a giant LexA 4 flex it's a it's a
huge it has sensors so big and Scott
says enough anyway I lost my [ __ ]
mind
and I started screaming about the most
so it that carried on put your hands on
your my father my father went like this
as I'm yelling at my mom and I continued
the argument as my mother goes you don't
know you get intimacy no one ever hit
the moose there's only two moose my
daughter's downstairs she's mad at me
she said I go my daughter's mad at me
now and my father looks at me and goes
this is what I live with every day oh
damn it I don't know how you rid of
those triggering things I have no idea
you know what my father does my dad I my
father's been married to my mother for
55 years goes away I can't find him yeah
he goes away right I know I can't find
him it's in the house and I hear like
there's a screen there's a big screen we
have this old screen right here I go
hello gonna go hey
everyone has no no no are you hiding
behind the screen he visit your mother
keeps calling me I go I know but we this
zone is beautiful I don't know yeah I
don't know how you ever get rid of those
triggering you can't I don't think you
ever can
oh what'd he say so you guys come on
they talk let's go I go
I'd lose my mind the Papa here in my
husband just certain things it's hot
let's go wow man
yeah I don't know if like you do with it
my father doesn't kept trying to teach
my son Italian we're not telling you
don't speak Italian
hey Jeb going say ciao Tigers like what
he's fluent in Spanish in English she
say Chinese they could pick it up easily
but why because if he if he speaks three
like but you don't speak Italian so you
teach them child I don't know where but
you're wasting your time did my father
this is this is the one trigger i of my
father because we played golf as a kid
and he would so I would I would i putt I
don't play golf dude I don't care I play
once a year with him I love feeling yeah
don't don't I don't care don't go so I I
so I putt and he'll go like this I /
putt and he'll go
no you slapped it slapped call man no
slapped at it bang hey you better shut
up man and then he was the same you know
what else old guys do that they I mean I
love my dad he's very very knowledgeable
on cars and sports but the old guys
don't fact-check anything so like I was
talking about a gt2 RS and this Aston
Martin and my dad goes you know I think
he's like you know he doesn't know just
be right heard someone else say it's the
same thing we recurse date brighter in
the locker room with his other old
friends and he's all you know the gt2 RS
is actually a rougher ride than that
than the gt3 r it's that's not true it's
actually a rougher ride and I just don't
think you won't even fit you won't fit I
oh well no that's not true and then we
get in the beat just right away I'm like
hold on no no look look at my phone I'll
just actually bring up the review I can
bring it up dude there's no more bro
science in that finally kid this bro
science we spit yeah but engine when it
comes to fact my mom one thing about my
father is he's he's so [ __ ] thorough
with his facts
he's so thorough my mother is not my
mother goes by intuition my mother
walked by me the other day nothing
drives me crazy because she finds cancer
everywhere and she'll just go she walked
by and she goes
hey your stomach is not a normal shape
lately that stuff I go that's not that's
categorically untrue she goes well
something's not enormous that walks out
you know she said though you know I mom
asked for 15 tickets next weekend you
gotta give it to him nope no I went mom
no one has money yeah I give to you yeah
in the family but I went where they
taught you well my friends at work or
family Oh mom come on yeah fifth you
know my mom and my father at their 80
now you know they're both very healthy
thank God I don't know but at 80 they
said you know we just keep looking
around and all our friends start dying
or they have they get some crazy disease
really yeah but um what's interesting is
that my mother said I don't think being
skinny helps you in the long run
and I went what do you mean she goes did
this tally about all our friends that
every one of her friends worked out and
stays super thin their whole life they
all get something bad they all just died
or 80 every single one of them like they
uh I mean I don't think that's a
scientific study but it was working
sometimes it'll be like I agree come on
but but though the ones that are really
skinny like especially the joggers
especially the ones that do a lot of
long-distance running apparently just
you know [ __ ] hmm maybe it's
important for your mom's friends yeah
it's not a scientific study really I
wonder though do your parents ever to
get stronger
yeah joggers little mamas what triggers
you it's oh it always has to do with my
weight cuz I was always the chubby one
of my family
do you were you affect your not heavy I
always I was chubby for the Mike the
group of my cousins that I grew up with
but I fear thick like curvy chubby like
chubby like eight like little Asian baby
chubby [ __ ] yeah like I was always like
a smaller kid because I was Asian and
I'm just genetically smaller but amongst
my cousins I was always the chubby r1
and every single time I gained any
weight they make it seem like I don't
notice it myself they're like hey you
know you gained weight I'm like fat
shaming work I'm like yes I I know dude
think I look in the mirror every single
day do you not think I'd make sure it
doesn't make me self-conscious I just
don't like that they bring it up all the
time and they bring it up as if I don't
know do me a favor to give you a complex
growing up with it yes oh my gosh yes
what happened whatever you're doing you
I think you look fantastic
I think you look adorable timepi yeah
you look are you working out still
you're doing all right yeah I'm working
out a guy who couldn't look better
thank you right she looks amazing yeah
let me just see this
so do distance runners a little longer
plotting druggers tended to live longer
than those who ran faster that might
just be they said these are tricky
though there's live and live an average
of three if you have smoke give me good
right in your diet all that [ __ ] this
one says sorry doesn't make you live
longer well you know the ice though yeah
that's bro science yeah um but it's okay
you did you grow up with a like a body
issue yeah I don't think parents
realized how big of a deal that is yeah
and I don't think I noticed that I I
didn't come to the realization that I
was never over wait until I got older
and I looked back at photos I was like
yo I was tiny that's like a hundred of
15 pounds yeah I thought I was so much
fatter than I was Oh in that way yeah
and then I got a real mean streak
wearing like 18 I had enough yeah I have
a body who everybody in this room has
body issues I got well I think if you
have to rocking like y'all do I like I
mean it's just that we know that does
anyone who looks in the mayor's like all
perfect they saw some people would I
read a matter I don't know me I don't
know anybody in the mayor who looks
looks and goes perfect yeah no way you
talk to the rock you talk to some of
these some people even obviously people
I work out like crazy that's the reason
they work out like crazy right I mean
that's about 100 percent yeah
like bodybuilders are fighting oh dude
oh that's I watched mr. Olympia this
weekend Saturday night
there are boy nobody watch bills not in
it he boycotted right can you look at
why Phil's not it because he law he lost
he last year last year's a very kind of
fun so yeah I don't know why he's not it
but hey
last year's winner accused of rape and
you tall shout out to your parents house
oh boy
she's a wreck oof tall and why is he not
Phil Heath will not commit the biggest
unanswered question heading to miss
tonight I'll get to the
it was whether or not my okay initially
no brand that heat would be taking this
year off of competition and 70 a streak
of winning and Limpy is broken by shawn
rhoden who is doing in trouble
he's not he would take this year off
ever news broke that Roden would be
unable to compete the air fall that
people began speculating okay keep going
down this way alright okay okay I'm
thankful to finally now say I'm not
competing this year's Olympia throughout
my career to create base where I will be
sitting this year out okay I haven't
stopped raining I've chosen bypass this
year's event so no definitive reason I
just wanted a break right I mean maybe I
don't know but yes some mother she went
down to would with the judging but dude
body Billings died in the United States
so there's no there's no Miss Olympia
anymore because nobody cares no one
what's the big thing surly chick right
so but with this one yeah I watched this
one dude it was like the stream quality
was so low at 18,000 people watching it
one thought it's just body but why is
that that's I guess I enjoy it has my
uncle Pat's is super into it so I got
into when I was younger kid has it
always did have a running dude hey I'm
one who's Jay Cutler Ronnie Coleman when
is Phil Heath Kai green Arnold I think
that might have been also before people
knew the level of steroids because
thinks though I just think there's some
there like it's a little bit like
there's no there's no entertainment like
it's no I don't know yeah don't have any
static - static stuff stars very yeah
it's what we gonna say rig a sport about
it
man judging other men well just was not
an outside beauty contest the strides in
this back Todd he looks incredible yeah
it's a beauty contest men I met yeah
which is whatever I mean the discipline
it takes become that Treadway I listen
when people go it's steer it okay take
the exact you could members are taken
you're never gonna get there yeah it's a
combination of comics when really hard
work all technique I mean getting your
body like that takes it's just constant
work I mean you know you've got you
Phil great yeah smart dude oh yeah and
it's a science I mean you can say
whatever you want about steroids it's a
science fits diet it's exercise again
lowering the roar of the gun the left
was there saying a lot about this guy
that Iranian wolf he won he got third
what about him he's the author there's
the winner up above right there all
right that's their show Jack but of
course yeah there was no Miss Olympia
this year
look at his quads small small legs
though honey's keeps going down okay
check out the hem is strange getting
your body like that is nuts though look
at the legs there showed what's funny to
me is people think how about he's 48
he's fifth place he's 40 nights wheeler
bro that's flex wheeler yeah
is that flex of that deck sir where it
that's flex wheeler hold on don't worry
he's still doing the damn thing for
thigh flex wheeler was in the Miss that
that's incredible 48 48 dude look at how
shred it is how about chocolate bodies
oh shut up
chuckle Abati's go-go pad I mean I've
never seen flex look at the veins it's
so weird his chest looks smaller than it
should be though I got a problem how
dare you he's jacked you're judging
look at that strike we finished fourth
that's sick that's a little peepees
though you know why because they're so
dehydrated and then remember Donna let's
tear all the testosterone the steroids
you're nuts go our work here is done
thank you
pack up our bags and take it up top and
they disappear who is that that might be
flex wheeler nope
excuse me you know your [ __ ] all right
take it easy man I don't know that guy
looks like his face I've been flex
wheeler chin flakes where they come pick
on the the the hey I got your anavar huh
I got your anavar I know you want to
take it you take it I want to see Ashley
this is no not-not-not flex wheeler what
is his [ __ ] name they calm the blade
typing the blade body builder the blade
dude not flex wheeler
you said the blade the blade decks the
blade body boy Dexter Jackson I said
what I say dr. wheeler
it's Dexter Jackson bro 48 years old
doing the damn thing
he won mr. bean but not this year but
yeah that's his face yeah that's him bro
look at what you say about his chest
[ __ ] guys got a chest on ya dude that
guy's got a chest remember we've got a
[ __ ] on there when I when I remember
I was flexing and and and Phil Heath
goes well you can use some incline bench
I I did I started I've never stopped
doing in climbing yes now this doesn't
work for me just can't put on muscle
yeah but I'm gonna limp it used to be
such a bigger deal even though the
convention is being in Vegas now you
hear anything about it know that the
Orleans now it's got a SATA throw a wee
performance and now from the fighter and
the kid stages do here's a trivia for
people out there which I can't hear you
answer back so here you go
the very first lie find the kid was
weird do you remember old man hold on
does anyone in here know hold on hold on
yeah I do go ahead it was in it was at
the Brea improv no no answer a question
and nope the very first line very first
time you and I ever went live I think it
was in Vegas correct I'd be at the MMA
UFC oh yes the UFC Expo I remember that
and I will kick that yep on stage it was
great
that's how long ago that was very first
time we were on stage
damn they're live yeah you were fighting
I was when Cain was yep I was doing
autograph signing the champion I go to
the stage and [ __ ] crazy huh dude how
long ago was that I don't know we've
been doing this a long time brother when
would that that was in Vegas finally kid
UFC Expo did you watch out in the UFC
fights this weekend sir those two I'm 14
they're international yep that's it
wonder may 18 2015 5 years ago yeah
start spike your throat we've been doing
the pike is thrown with six years now
seven we look different when we started
you know it did men um your neck did you
watch the UFC I did man did you know I
didn't want to watch cowboy lose oh come
on you're just busy and forget to watch
it you always watch Joey yeah I just
want to watch it yeah I didn't thought I
was gonna win I didn't you didn't no no
no really
mm-hmm just a breath fight for him what
do what explain stylistically and then
also cowboy whenever he's fighting a guy
that he's friendly with he never
performs at his highest level he needs
that adversity so he's friendly with
Justin they used to be trained predators
oh [ __ ] same camp stuff like that oh
just a knife is it suck to see why why
is just engaging the rumor is even get
Connor Nick because Justin Doe is such a
push forward kind of fight all pressure
donald's slow started Gaetti the fast
star in the UFC oh because I just feel
like Diane Donald one song gets your
rhythm then he starts piecing you up
just me give you a check it is rhythm
this goes well awful matchup for did
Glover win yeah not the best for Todd
Duffee Todd Duffee back
he won nope I poked in the eye all right
mmm that's a bummer yeah um she Tyson
Fury I don't know did you ride a haul
win yeah I don't go through did you ride
a haul win yep that's what it says right
yeah hmm uh fury won though he had the
biggest cut on his I saw that cut out
he's about to lose it's crazy if they
would stop the fight had a head but no
left hook that's why furious corner
thought it was a headbutt and they're
like oh cool if they stop it will go to
the judges scorecards or it'd be a draw
or no contest but as a left hook oh my
god this sweet blast him with a left
hook is filthy and the guy was not white
I was it was there was there uh I mean
that looks like a shark bite looks like
the [ __ ] head what what what happened
with um it was the guy giving it to him
was it a very close fight the first five
rounds is five six rounds were you know
the Swede was definitely when maybe half
of them but then for you
took over Jews but that's why I fight
though that's why you Vaseline your face
right that's why the matter Vaseline
they put on his face was insane
yeah but thank God to the bond they
close that and if I like that how don't
and when when did that happen what route
fourth round
Oh different yeah what can you fought
the distance here's for throwing out
sounds right head in it and then between
rounds you know that Bell ding ding are
like night or 10th round the sweet takes
his club and rubs thymic yeah terrible
what really that's had nauseous great
fight though watch that the cut made it
that just way more exciting oh I think I
was out there I've been a boy yeah it
was super excited I got because you're
worried yeah you stop over and then the
entire boxing world
[ __ ] hmm I didn't know that I thought it
was just a I thought it was I got held a
contest or huh but man thank God when
does rule around when does Ruiz Joshua
I'm excited about and then Wilder starts
in third that happened the third round
out or first Ortiz is in November
well that's gonna be exciting
although Ortiz is so much older though
idea might be 6922 what about when it's
spent porter 28 summer 20 a.m. I can't
well I do it's nowhere it's just not
happening
hmm let's kill some current events kids
cool you have to that even fat spotted
dick go for your pistol anybody tell you
something right now dude alpha brain
alpha brain instant new mood melatonin
spray for a good night's sleep
yeah you want you got some problems with
your gut I had food poisoning took the
total gut health guess what Kieran had
problems to do with my gut uh-huh total
gut health you want to get some you want
to get some omega-3 fatty acids that's
why krill oil apparently the most of you
know what about the earth grow nutrients
you want to get you
work out and not be tired trash room
tech commute and that room tech a sport
I use that I don't do the shrimp tech
immune I've used that before maybe let
me you're an active dude you'll have a
lot of time now how about you work out
at home yeah how about that dude yeah
how much you go home and work out with
on it six body weight kettlebell steel
may streaming fitness well we're talking
about that streaming fitness is the
thing I got to start doing you do you
need to do the chest one I'm gonna look
into it for you okay but you need to get
on your chest yeah okay I'm gonna dad
today I'm gonna do the streaming Fitness
today look up bird chat see what comes
up what just saying dude I don't like
that alright honored concise fighter 10%
off everything we just told you about on
it calm slash fighter okay so to twenty
year olds men were arrested because they
went to a McDonald's drive-through at
like 3:00 to 4:00 in the morning they
got their food came back in the
drive-thru pulled out a gun on the guy
who was working and said that their that
their food was cold and not to play with
them and their food this is frustrating
and so the McDonald's worker ended up
calling the police and by the time the
police got there they were still in the
drive-thru and they said that they were
just kidding and that they were playing
around they sound like they they think
things through they get arrested they
got arrested the weapon permits
nope they do not have permits they got
arrested for
yeah pulling a gun out on the McDonald's
worker and also they had some drugs in
the car
crazy talk what smart guys there's been
a string of events where people are just
going apeshit on people working in
drivers do die when they [ __ ] up your -
it is so frustrating if you weren't
mature enough to deal with it whatever
post mates and they forget like this the
sauce that makes the meal when they
forget it Oh bro oh I'm like how how
dude god damn it poori on I'm not gonna
pull a gun I'm gonna leave you one-star
review and you're still another
drive-thru it post means is different
cuz once it's there there's nothing I
there's nothing you do I have to just
but also don't take off me
everybody knows the drive-through thank
you here's your food thank you i go
through everything check it thank you oh
can I get the bar boom
I don't leave I never check every Tainan
special tannic people hide you know it's
true everybody waiting well what's it
drive-through what else yeah so do you
guys remember the storm area51 raid yep
so the creator of the Facebook page
ended up creating a music festival in
its place ik and he tried to call it
alien stock because he knew he could
have all these people go to area 51
another he saw yeah and he saw an
opportunity you want to create his own
festival where people who had thought
the same way and where like-minded would
go show up listen great music exactly
but he ended up pulling out last week
because he said that he didn't have the
ability to put on a festival properly
it's a lot goes up with big people I
tried to do a Comedy Festival in
Sundance by your so I know I had I had
people who have a lot of money and it
would do it into it and then I we we
really got went down the rabbit hole I I
had the moths I have the guy who runs
the whole time no you can't make money
you just candles festivals or herbs they
have to be supported by the state you
just the vendors and stuff you just
can't monster yeah it's a monster
there's so much goes into it like a
Comedy Festival seems like a great idea
Sundance Film Festival let's do a comic
done it's Comedy Festival way more way
more later but yeah I mean I like being
part of you don't make money Just for
Laughs is financed by the Canadian it's
literally just for laughs yes correct
you got to put people this guy it was a
good idea he capitalized not like the
alien fest that's sick
yeah he was afraid of being fire
festival 2.0 there's that yeah there's
that but at least he tried doing
something positive with it just didn't
work out
they could all still met in Vegas and
like talk to aliens or some [ __ ] dressed
the holloway a lot of the people who
were initially trying to go to that
event are actually now going to meet up
in the Vegas Strip and just kind of
hanging out see that's what they should
do i it was often the guy started this
campaign as a joke you didn't think
you'd gain legs so it's pretty funny
today I'm talking about
I think people understood to is like
area 51 is a military base oh it's the
the military doesn't [ __ ] around
no the military's like guys listen
please don't do it if you do it we're
gonna be forced to deal with ya and you
don't want you think we're afraid of
civilian oh you think we're worried
about you coming in Oh sweetie yeah
everybody [ __ ] yeah every pet you're not
gonna you're gonna hide aliens forget
that they don't have to do any of no use
tear gas if you see what tear gas does
to crowds ask Tokyo the people in Tokyo
Hong Kong yeah
or do you have the same life thing in
this I know no but we can pull it up
have you seen what's going on there no
sorry I've hired a new a comic and he
was doing a podcast while ago and it's
very strange because if those so
everyone's trying to get him fired for
life because he did this old bit on a
podcast for about agents and it's night
it's like I watched I'm like God man
that's it it's didn't this this this
culture we're in this toxic culture here
and what bothers me it's some other
comics month this is ridiculous get him
fired have you seen Sam triply going up
people online yeah Sam's like get the
I'll remember this [ __ ] like you
guys want to screw this guy over biggest
day of his life and Anthony Jeselnik had
the best thing goes oh I'm so happy to
see when a comic has one of the biggest
days of his life someone tried to [ __ ]
bring him down yeah guys we're now yeah
but have you seen it it did let you have
you have you guys watched it
mmm they might bring up Shang Gillis you
can fly with it what with a cop car what
was the joke about it he went to an
Asian restaurant how hard is to order
you should see it I watched on it I see
way more Dicer stuff and then never how
about how about [ __ ] a dead Dave
Chappelle hundun and I he was like
talking about being Chinese I'm Chinese
now remember yep I remember that you I
mean we're so ridiculous now but but
it's all I guarantee spine not even
Asians it's probably white people gone
we're two werewolves oz doh
[ __ ] tone that's that's the one I
think that got him in trouble you
watched that that out that again I don't
know all of it but I know that's I
watched that that was what was on
Twitter so go to that one and you got as
asian-americans telling you this offend
you so that's him there just gotta get
you saying like biggest deal ever
forgotten started they just built one
[ __ ] up looking building and people
are like all right no one said anything
well they built these [ __ ] like huge
Shanghai out the first one the chinks
coming or not what are you saying that's
how they were thinking hey you know what
yeah true also I'm always like how could
there be so many [ __ ] restaurants
down here all rest you go in there's
like one person eating out it's like
neuters I hate you I hate the food of
Chinese how it sucks Chinese foods are
very dishonest cuisine they invented a
[ __ ] chemical to put in their food to
make it delicious dude they made us a
msg it's a dishonest food dude there's
nothing there's nothing to it it's
shitty shitty meat a chemical they made
up to [ __ ] your body up and noodles
neuters see the biggest promise a
terrible policy in the world keep going
though chemical cuz you'll hear
everything you can find we got in there
and we sat down and this is what came up
so excited for new ders and I was like
yo chill chill she said new ders yeah
[ __ ] yeah and it's it's [ __ ] shiny
in there isn't that kind of like nice so
it's not being when when people go and
illegal Mexican restaurant like I'll two
tacos on the bowl of spicy neuters but
we had in the translation between you
and the waiter yeah it was just such a
[ __ ] hassle it's like can you I'm
pointing it that's why I put number of
like 57 yeah this one even with the
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay point I was like that
sauce that one
like medium oh yeah like medium that's
it that that was our in my office
we know what he's saying there's no way
this white they want to find out that he
said it let me have God says [ __ ] I
wonder how that started they just built
one [ __ ] up looking building and
people are like all right no one said
anything so he's referring to other
people that's right I mean I don't think
it's C and that is where people scroll
but can you google it has to be
something else there's no way you won't
get them five from Stan's library hi
there's no way it's crazy
um Shane Chinese oh that's resurfaced
Rose the community third using racial
slur against see that that's it yeah
nineteen change secret China's [ __ ]
nuts he says at one point in the
conversation just since been deleted let
the [ __ ] chinks live there yeah
honestly it's that's it dude yeah I
wouldn't care
Wow cat I don't my biggest thing is I
don't think it was a very good podcast I
don't think it's anything to get in arms
about I mean yeah I hear somebody over I
mean yeah oh no they're calling for his
job you know what Lauren Michaels is
doing nothing
good for him Thank You Lauren he's so
talented Tom Thank You Lauren I thought
they said they fired him though did they
fire me no way over that ah yeah he's
don't [ __ ] he's out oh no way Wow [ __ ]
you oh my [ __ ] yeah that was 40 minutes
ago yeah Wow Wow because I'm a podcast
let's see if he was fired if he's just
not doing it that's right most their net
virtual history I've talked with Shane
Gillis we have decided that he will not
be joining satellite from whence a
bright voice we were not aware of his
prior remarks that have surfaced over
the past few days the language he heard
is offensive
[ __ ] you ah [ __ ] you that's that's
amazing
I feel it feels ridiculous for me to be
making serious public statements but
here we are I'm a community was funny
enough together that can't be taken away
of course I wanted an opportunity proved
himself of us no but I understand it
would be too much for a distraction you
know what I feel bad for Shane Gillis he
put I was always the mad guy but I was
always a mad TV guy anyway haha [ __ ] man
I feel bold my here John bad for that
guy he lost see but discount this cancel
culture that we live in
yeah so who saw so so so this is what
happens you get you lose your [ __ ]
the biggest opportunity your life
because you were making an offhand
comment about what other people say and
you were saying it's true it's true you
go down a good trying to tell and the
guy doesn't speak English at all and you
know there's gonna be confusions it's
saying the word chinks which come in
trouble he was saying that's what people
that would that was that's that's what
people say oh my god it doesn't mean
he's racist you're not dealing with a
racist here you know wasn't funny though
that's not like if he can't pointed out
before too it's like it wasn't funny
it wasn't funny but it doesn't matter
but but how deeper we're gonna go for
this guy that did to Bruno I don't think
he should be fired Saturday night I
dived I mean wow good luck getting on
ass now you I'm screwed never happen my
dream now is what this what I mean
though just create your own worlds
[ __ ] corporations like Google
corporations like and that's now now and
and NBC's they are so afraid they're so
afraid to even be nuanced about things
oddly it's saying they fold to the
[ __ ] pressures not even pressure
they fold to this horseshit noise on
Twitter no hold on hold on listen this
[ __ ] on here goes it should go
without saying but Gil stream might
remains a popular profitable commune who
has under no definite definition been
cancelled if history has any indication
he stands a game from his notoriety I
hope he does at least at least people
are talking about him I'm sure he's a
good comic you know what supplies great
comic you know it's a bummer his other
colleagues went after him
really yeah what are the comics that you
guys know
yeah oh that sucks I don't know you know
I'm sure you guys could Google later no
one in our circle who are they that idle
Schumer no no you bring it up bring up I
don't I don't be part of that god
imagine gets the biggest call of your
life on satellite life the biggest call
and then a few days later people dope
dude that podcast she did however
[ __ ] long ago that time you've
referenced jinx you're not gonna find
out life Wow these Jimmy o yang cuz he's
a he's an Asian comic so I comic I'm on
the same bill of all the time he's a
great comic he put his Caminos you side
with comedians on thin subjects but this
is just plain racist it's truly
disgusting stand up against this is just
as important to support our Asian
brothers and sisters see how Zion has to
go I'm not Chinese I will say this I've
said this yeah that's not Chinese before
a times Chinese people in this country
have dealt with our [ __ ] load of racism
and a fuckload of violence and I like a
way more than people know they just have
they don't they just don't voice it but
there is no question that that shot
people of Chinese descent
Metheny Chinese all over the world have
done incredibly well in every culture
there immerse themselves in because
their culture frugality and all that and
and and hard work and all that but they
have dealt without fuckload not only of
prejudice but but but like literal
massacres let me ask you right I mean
you say Gillis's racist no but I know
that's my point
I understand people's sensitivity but
what Shane gills here was doing was
referencing how other people were
talking about that in a very offhand
comment and to take it away I got a
problem
even when Daniel D Kim says this he's
not seen in the same context he was
asked to be a joke in there somewhere
he's reference is an awful podcasting
the contents not good he/she
firing for having a bad podcast not for
being racist scroll up who's the other
comic W come on girl I don't know two
Nobel goes hard imabelle fan
he's on CNN here's a shot see none
really come on Bell is brilliant man at
CNN he's I really like him so what's he
saying that's it's a joke that's already
been done and yeah I don't make those
Joe comics and TV I don't make those
jokes and I've always been fairly
sensitive to this only because I have a
little bit I've read a little bit about
what it is to be chinese-american
country it's not easy and hasn't been
until very recently
remember when in Indira's he crazy rich
Asians when those when they came into
the hotel and the hotel maitre d was
very rude to them that was a reality
that's what Chinese people dealt with
all the [ __ ] time and then they got
to a point where they had a lot of money
and trying to earn their right in place
in the world so I understand that people
are very sensitive
once again this guy Shane Gillis is not
the bad guy I don't think he's racist
and we have to be careful keep going
after the people like this if he's the
bad guy everybody's the bad guy
ng Inc says he's for the record Thank
You Andrea it doesn't believe he should
lose his job there you go I like that
that's really this is a part of the best
Thank You yang previously Gilles
referred to yang as a Jew [ __ ] [ __ ] in
episode of my last podcast my community
that must be it
cuz I remember she was a you can--this a
Jew change you or something that someone
said you articles kept on referring to
the comedian saying something about yang
as like a Jew [ __ ] I don't know I
couldn't find a footage from it though
so that so what from what I saw if that
was it but I I'm with what I just saw
that podcast I don't think she juice
from what I saw there's no way that men
should not been sent that's how I feel
and Andrea agrees although you ting is
yeah that's a normal thing to call
somebody again I yeah III tricky road
when you when you didn't go back over
time what comedians say and then go dude
four years ago you said this works with
different culture different core I'm
trying to be funny I'm gonna podcast and
my friend yeah what can you do yeah it's
it's my problem with it is this what do
you think I feel that most people are
like if you want to go after the bad
guys find the bad guy
that's what I'm saying there are plenty
of bad guys yeah fighting this is this
is this is not the guy to get rid of
this doesn't mean if this is um such
low-hanging fruit there are bad people
and go after those guys yeah I think
this is a waste of ammo I really do and
I think if you start doing this with
people like bike ham and you start
getting them fired when you have to go
after the real bad guys you're not gonna
be as potent no you've you shouldn't
yeah and the other thing what's like
that uh in Australia I forget what she
does but she the US the US he's going
there you know that big Whitacre of her
style bender yeah she wants to not allow
the ring car girls in she was in in this
movement how are we gonna have ring car
girls like hold on that's the way they
make money do you think you're pushing
the women's right agenda forward who is
this one who said Sally cap she's like
the mayor Lord of Melbourne Melbourne
bring her up let me look what she do how
do you think she looks bright
I would imagine she wouldn't Mesa 7 a
hot I would imagine she wouldn't make
the cut as a ring-card girl but let me
just take a look at her do you think
there's some weird jealousy going on -
sure ever it's not terrible but she she
banned oil bunnies in NASCAR there so
she doesn't want but but also that's not
your [ __ ] place to do that
girls are employed this that's within me
so what about playboy can you not make a
living
pozole hold on so are women not supposed
to use their bodies to make mining I
guess Madden do it yeah Thunder Down
Under
yeah they're all Australians right yes I
guess they're being objectified huh cuz
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking money and food other mouths so
do you think you're pushing the agenda
forward they see you know many girls
want that guy she sucks you suck cuz she
doesn't get laid exactly get out of here
get out of here get a [ __ ] politician
shame kill stuff Maga so man who loves
power these people want to control
everybody in some better news did you
guys see a video of a little boy giving
away free food last week I don't nobody
should be scolded for that he's only six
year old Jermaine Bell was saving up
money to go to Disney World for his
birthday
when Hurricane durian started to come
he was in South Carolina with his
grandparents a lot of people were
leaving Florida and making their way up
toward South Carolina he decided to use
all of the money he was saving up for
his birthday trip to Disneyworld to buy
water and food and just give it out to
people who were leaving the area and
Disneyland this is obviously never rode
Magic Mountain Disney ended up
surprising him with a paid vacation
that's great that's such a big deal for
a little kid oh he's the cutest thing
sure you feel this video here mm-hmm
that's the video that went viral okay no
one's staying in the hotel it's a lot of
ships dude I had some Beaumont Venice
asked me if I won this chili dog I know
I'm good I went ads before would you buy
from are you fingers on it do I rent I
don't eat chili dogs for 11 a.m. I'm an
otherwise a twit he goes right on right
on maybe next time
next time yeah or never don't your chili
dog yeah what else we got shot for this
kid yeah hero goddamn hero so there's
another student-teacher sex scandal and
I just wanted to get your opinion on
this teacher before I tell you more has
a square jaw I find her I find her kind
of a track I find it kind of attractive
little bit of mustache not mad though
again I better looking than any teacher
I've ever had besides Miss familar huh
shut up to second grade Virginia Court
Dyke she's probably go on I feel like I
mean I find all these teachers are
fairly attractive who have always women
teachers it's very on is it a man she is
no she is 26 years old and she is the
danced heat the dance coach at a high
school and she got fired because she
admitted after undergoing an
investigation she admitted to having a
romantic relationship with a female
student
whoo all right
again I'm slime licks box kind of fine
with it all but how old is the female
student um high school she's like 16 15
you can see how would have happened I
don't know I mean I don't think anybody
was coerced here I can see what
she loses her job yeah yeah well I have
to see the girl they're both hot let me
do it I mean but also she admitted to
kissing the girl not necessarily
anything sexual but still though you
just can't do that
I'm sorry hey be a school administrator
I gotta go hey she's just 5:15 Sporto
we're technically a child be here you
got a daughter let's say you're dark a
moment dad I'm kind of dating this girl
yeah what all right okay so you're gay
that's another issue
not that I care about that and she's
like well it's the teacher how old she
26 how's my daughter 15 here's the thing
you have a huge problem here's the thing
I that you can't do that
you gotta get fired you can't you get to
trial this is I'll say that's shame
guilt uuuugh your 15 year old daughter
is not hearing a peep out of you as a
father
you're 15 our daughters gonna be like
I'm already losing control my daughter
my daughter is already basically going
No yeah and I have to be like well
you're not getting your iPad or
something there's no review how hot
these girls are though man
well can we get a better picture I don't
know what will we get her there dude the
[ __ ] look though why the wet slip
though not [ __ ] the derogatory term
smelly I didn't know what that means
what what is that what does that
derogatory term come from bent over in
the Sun sweat no one your wedding I
heard it was when you're running across
the border yeah you're gonna be on
you're gonna be going through like
rivers or whatever string yeah look at
that derogatory have you ever you know
that where the term cracker comes from
yes
cracking a whip crack it the slang whip
so the black people would call the white
slave owners crackers just not a good
racial name for white guys is there
nothing that hits home well that's
because white guys weren't in a position
where they were being no I fully
understand the history of it what I'm
saying I have to teach you there's
nothing I know we're good I'm what I'm
saying is there's no like bad like honky
or what crack and the funny though
it's called Baccarin hongki's okay
[Music]
crossing the room you lied to Mexicans
who enter us Texas surely right getting
wet in the prop
you know as well they are waiting across
the river and getting wet in the process
Jesus well that's the problem with
labeling people a noun keep going chin
all right thanks for looking up [ __ ]
no problem
apologies ahead of time Brian but a lot
of people were tagging us in this so
there's this thing called wrinkles the
clock got dere you guys good rink has
really stuck I got some girls who are
like I don't think you're wrinkly
good-looking that's where this comes
from but I guess this is a crazy clown
that it's like a I guess it's real like
parents hired this clown to scare their
kids when they're doing bad stuff yeah
so this is a trailer that I'll just play
the trailer we won't this is like his
promo to hire this is a movie it's the
documents coming out on what terrible
parents I don't know if it's real high
wrinkles oh no who would do that to
their that's why I think chime who knows
this is really really real I think it's
real I think it's a movie well got my
ghost story this is the kids documentary
who knows the clown ranks now how was
that we on location for how long how
many did you take to shoot that well I
like that I like that I have you use
much make that what they didn't what
they would do is just apply white paint
as Isis and my skin get creases so I
don't really need a mask do I would
shoot that [ __ ] clown if my girl
hired that and he came home I see yeah
well John Wayne Gacy the famous serial
killer killed 30 dude don't get me
started on two killers he was a gone for
a you know John Wayne Gacy he was a
clown you know I drove by Sharon Tate's
house the other night right no got very
scared turn around
all right now be Antonio Brown stuff so
as you know he's accused of rape hold
wild allegations this little ballplayer
got traded to the Coral Gables you left
the Raiders got traded to the Pats now I
was playing for the sign of the fact oh
I'm ok he's being sued by this girl damn
Brittany Taylor who was his what he
called you it's a trainer but it's more
like a like physical therapy tough stuff
yourself right ok you know the history
behind them no like he apparently jacked
off I don't when dude she was turned
around and then came on her back that
was one of them then he actually
forcibly raped her after all these
different things he said yes so she says
and then she even worked with him after
like some of these events - all right
she came back office if any two million
dollars or I'm gonna make this public
and we'll go [ __ ] yourself then she made
it public I'm always I always give the
sign of me - haha especially because so
let's talk about this so if you if you
got raped
it is despite the biggest story if you
got raped do you care about two million
dollars they want to make sure there's
he's prosecuted so some way so if you if
you weren't if you were if you got raped
uh-huh
okay can I read this text to you yes
like yeah and the toy what you think now
I'm gonna do my best and I know a speech
impediment and my my reading levels not
talent level but this is really his
wording you ready i jacked my dick on
your back slept with you in bed [ __ ]
your knowledge [ __ ] I've been all
all-pro before I even knew you you hit
me up online [ __ ] crying I didn't hit
you up you never left my house since you
had a hotel you feel it you feel asleep
on my couch [ __ ] out here my baby mama
tricky dumbass doom ass blast me or
failure telling everybody you own a gym
what you going blast don't [ __ ] write
my phone line [ __ ] thought it was easy
to get a come-up using God - fake
[ __ ] you and your mama thought y'all
hos had come up [ __ ] out here don't
write my team
thanks for giving us control of your
life for three weeks and it's time you
and your mom are plotting on a come-up
make sure all hoes pick the right man
dumbass hoes maybe somebody you already
[ __ ] your mom would control in your life
like she gonna help to come up you
failed at gymnastic you had nobody me
blocked out laugh about me and somebody
laugh about this [ __ ] me bustin on your
back boosting on your back smiley face
smiley face I'll let them know when I'm
bored you disgraced the little girls you
feel gymnastics they're gonna pass at
your mom's house with your mama luckily
I showed you around you're welcome my
baby mama no a weak [ __ ] when she spot
one you played yourself okay the best I
can do
this guy actually translated it name's
Sam Brunson and who is he
some guy that just translated perfectly
this won't start a game esteem to you
hey so you put AI jack laid my semen on
your back I slept in the same bed as you
you don't know any anything woman I've
been an all-pro wide receiver and then I
felt before I even knew you you
contacted me first out of desperation I
never contacted you you stayed at my
residence because you didn't have a
hotel and you fell asleep on my couch
please leave from here the mother of my
child fooled you excuse me you're a
failure despite telling everyone you own
a gymnasium or gymnasium what are you
going to accuse me of don't contact my
phone you're a liar that tried to profit
off my good fortune you are fake you and
your mother thought your prostitutes had
an easy way to profit you were wrong
don't contact myself he did come out are
strong and that's interesting he came
out of pretty strong he came out media
before ii was like i'm gonna check your
jaw next time I see you so what is what
is this what is this about what what is
the we have any so she's meeting with
NFL today with she's supposed to have
evidence I'm sure I remember she said
that she could pass a lie-detector test
or she passed a lie-detector test
talking about it but that means nothing
sociopaths that doesn't mean anything
actually trying to get money my biggest
thing is this if she asks for two
million dollars after it happened if you
had a rapist who did that you you you're
your moral obligation should be you go
to jail prison because if you get too
many knows he's out there raping people
right so so so you owe it to the other
yeah and also if you if you got raped
for real that's a
criminal that that's where you go
wouldn't you go right to that I know
that some women get raped they don't go
to the police I know that I'm not gonna
say there's a lot of stuff that goes on
but my my my skeptical I get skeptical
when I hear somebody said give me two
million dollars or I'm Gor I'm going to
go to the police now I'm like oh wait
him another one came out today though
another an artist cuz she was painting a
mural in his house this one's a little
dicey took to me would I do it
absolutely not but she says she was
painting in his house he came downstairs
with just a towel over his dick and
tossed it he didn't say suck it or
nothin but she felt uncomfortable why
he's a good-looking dude who probably
was like here's my body let's see if she
does something and she didn't want the
organs coroner's Sophia Hanson Brown
liked the painting so much they trumped
the would be winning bid of 450 okay
hand said they took brown okay okay
brown was so delighted to portrait okay
hired her you act like you trust me
after arriving at his home her second
day however that must fear the artist
says at one point she was in kneeling
position while painting turned to the
fine Brown behind her naked hole no
small towel over his genitals he was
flirty with me but I paid no mind I was
on there on business plus I've seen him
with multiple girls and the short time I
was with him I was about 40% done the
second day I'm on my knees painting the
bottom and he walks up to my walks up to
me but ass naked with a hand cloth
covering his dick and starts having a
conversation she took it as a clear
sexual come-on unfortunate I've been
tried by men a lot of times so I just
kept my cool kept painting after that he
you know it's all [ __ ] up though to do
that to a woman like I kind of believe
that why would she make that up
I believe it but here's the thing what
what charges are you gonna press right
hear me out here I'm not defendant when
I know that balaam a versus rain hold on
your how your you're in his house yeah
he's painting so he comes down this
would be the defense so he comes down in
the morning naked but with that covering
his genitals and then you know I was
like oh dope pill I don't know what he
said I'd have a problem with that that's
a clear come on and that's kind of
that's bad right I mean that's bad is it
against the law I don't know I don't
think it's against the law but it's
definitely yeah I understand in today's
day and age when women have to deal with
and she's there to world be I'm not
saying it's wrong I would never do the
sexual harassment that you know I read
this house you're in his house but you
see you had you for getting paid to do a
mural right yes a man who's like that
physically imposing first of all small
comes in with his hand over his penis no
Italo there's no but in this case he was
completely naked holding his dish but no
but maybe buff girl up [ __ ] me
no he's butt-naked on he was four on the
are says holding a small handheld I mean
so you the towel we have but it's a hand
cloth like that's so obviously to me
it'd be like that's crazy I would never
in a million years you're you know what
you're doing this person's they're
working I needs the money I agree you
come down there you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
here's the thing right everyone says
he's an [ __ ] I think it's confirmed
he's announced that that to me is clear
sexual harassment and you deserve at
least the you know women have had to
deal with this [ __ ] forever and never
had any recourse nowadays you can to
come out and be like this guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like I that's an [ __ ]
move that's how you're being a bunch of
[ __ ] I agree 100 cents a soul movie
she might have a guy there's so many
things are wrong with that [ __ ] thing
with him coming on her back would be a
completely does that would be assault
that so you're right so ass man then
there's a salt now a salt now but then
there's rape there's sexual assault and
rape is a whole nother accuse them of
rape yeah so rape sexual assault and
rape obviously we give a yachtie like
you know figure that out sex loose all I
think can even be a pat on the ass but
rape we know there are levels to this
game rape is a [ __ ] I mean hardcore
investigative thing now whether or not
it happened you never know you can't say
well shoes she contacted him after that
happens a lot women go back to the
trauma sides they scroll you if you
asked for two million dollars to keep
your mouth shut now i'm suspicious
because now you have a motive and now
you obviously weren't if you're if
you're you weren't that traumatized
you're like I know you're a rapist and a
really bad guy and rapists do this you
know it's not like they only read one
hey here's the other thing
give me too many dollars to keep my
mouth shut I gotta pose the other thing
again I'm not condoning his act at all
he did pay a $2,000
sent a $2,000 for the work I don't know
what the word job is worth because to
hunt knowledge there's not that um but
the artists hand through they want $700
for the original painting yeah I don't
know I don't know sounds like you I
don't like I don't like that behavior I
know he's an [ __ ]
yeah that's an [ __ ] movement he's an
ass and that is sexual harassment I feel
that be a form of thick you know I need
you I need the job I'm in your [ __ ]
house and you come down naked basically
[ __ ] you it's a problem for sure yeah
you see he's a spoiled [ __ ] has
always been a star he's a dick the other
thing is by the way you've been a star
you've been clapped for like like what's
his name Steve Harvey said you've been
clapped for and told you you're perfect
since you were eight nine when you were
special already and and you're basically
a prince you're basically treated like
royalty
you know this with with star athletes
like this you get your you're cocky you
think that the world belongs to you
right I mean here's the other here's the
thing Antonio Brown I'm sure has had
workers in this house before it's been a
situation where it does work out for
this end the first time he's done that's
right so he's had it where he's had a
female worker whether she's an assistant
or something where they do suck them
that's a good point so when he shoots
his shot I would imagine he should not
use 90% 90% so he come across the one
who's like what the [ __ ] you doing I'm
not defending Tony Brown what I'm saying
is in his world it's all yes so for him
she was living women and everything it's
all you yeah it's all yes so for him
it's not he was just like oh yes
probably she's probably into this right
thinks I'm sexy that's right he might
have said something work and do and
shook it as like oh she's down he's got
so her a lot of power that's receiving
that FL so he comes down she says no
he's like what the [ __ ] I will get
someone else he's like I say it's right
I mean that's his world yeah he's an
[ __ ] just don't shoot your shot like
this because you're normal yeah no he's
he said
he's batting 95% with girls yeah it
still makes him an [ __ ] yeah it's
just such a I'm not saying it's right I
would never do this even if you if we
had a
friend who did that we'd be like hey
dude that's a [ __ ] shitty move you
know I don't know I don't like that I
don't like I get it I get it well I
wonder what what's gonna happen you know
I'm saying with this nothing there's no
way this is what women are talking about
though a lot of women are like there you
go and then you ask every woman asked
any good-looking woman every single
woman you know has a story like this
right here's the problem they'll be ten
stories here's one of the problems is
again there's a lot of women who would
do this and would be flattered by this
well are already into him and they're
there and yeah well know the guy the guy
doesn't have trouble getting women
mm-hmm yeah I've seen and you've seen
way more I've seen like how these I've
had some experience with pro athletes
especially well-known pro athletes I
don't think anybody realizes I don't
think people realize like the access
they have it's almost like every girl
likes them it's the craziest [ __ ] you've
ever seen that's why they act like this
dude I was in Vegas with a very famous
athlete and I was watching this tonight
was like I've never seen anything like
it
married women it was the craziest [ __ ]
in the world hey my buddy was was
hanging out with Mike Tyson and this is
after he was fighting and he was in
Vegas and he goes dude he goes I'm
telling you I've in my friend was a
prophet himself because I've never seen
anything like dude Oh Jay women were all
done without O'Reily now yeah now that's
something I believe it destroys it I
believe it Oh Jay Simpson it's really
interesting it's a very weird [ __ ]
world's weird but but there's no
question that these but doesn't mean you
can do that but no here's my thing Tony
Brown there's a million women who will
be into this don't [ __ ] the painter dude
and you can have anyone also don't do it
find someone else yeah don't put her in
awkward I mean she might be a mom she
might be married Foust you might need
this game okay you're on it's a thousand
things wrong with it we call some other
girl off Instagram be smarter you know
what he thinks he owns the world because
he's been treated that way and he's he's
corrupt power corrupts load but power
corrupts but he's also a product of the
environment that he was raised it yeah
power curves a lot of takes up village
to make an [ __ ] you know they just
don't become [ __ ] on their own
the people he's surrounded with his
agents yeah team we didn't want to see
us as handsome because our mission is
all about feeling the good in people and
lifting people up part of me has to
believe that at some point one of these
grown men is going to realize they
shouldn't be stealing from a charity run
by black women benefitting children I
have to believe that yeah I think this
stuff is all good in the end when when
this [ __ ] comes to surface and we're all
talking about it the whines yeah I think
this - I think all of its good I think
that I think athletes are gonna be like
oh [ __ ] man like I can't or even
celebrities we've you know we know
people it does say here hold on he says
well Taylor was staying at Brown's house
in Miami Taylor was watching a Chow
service Brittany Taylor had when
according to her complaint Brown began
mass being near her without her
knowledge and ejaculated on her back and
they later bragged about the incident
and profane emails to Taylor Taylor
ended her working relationship with
brown but renewed it several months
later after he contactor apologized and
assured her he would cease any sexual
advances I mean if there's evidence of
that this is all gonna be looked at
yeah I'm forced her down under a bed
pushed her face into the mattress and
forcibly raped her look I don't know man
I don't know this situation I don't know
well I had notes statement I tell her to
invest 1.6 million dollars in a business
project we should receiver used to do
after learning that she had been levied
with a $30,000 IRS tax lien I don't know
man
I'm gonna say I don't know I don't know
I'd be a dirtbag but then she could be
lying about it I think they yeah how
about that I think they kind of thought
that probably they were in a it sounds
like they're in also in a relationship
she's a tax lien of $30,000 from the IRS
she wanted to invest in a project he
said no then they get a really ship it
hot we don't know yeah we don't know
what else you got we don't know that's
this is for the police yeah I guess what
do you think in this situation is he get
suspended or the NFL waits to see what
half they don't find anything no right
I heard there's not it can even be like
a criminal investigation if there's no
criminal investigation no people have
been playing this the diol burns before
we get it's just her it's like a civil
thing you know what I don't like is when
athletes thought they had only get in
trouble I hate when athletes just let
the lawyers
peak form if Interbrand might hold on
hon this what's happening she's a
beautiful girl
we weren't you and like told the story
like when we were engaged in
relationship she owned me invest in this
project and I'm working out
she has resentment you know like just if
you just come out and like tell us his
side and not have just as lawyers or hit
the higher-ups do it it goes so much
further but he can't write yeah yeah I I
wouldn't want my wife around tomorrow my
kid you know I would know he sounds like
an ass you see yeah you were talking
about how much of a pain in the ass he
was before all this stuff popped up Oh
night yeah here's a here though this is
a tall tale sign this has happened
someone before name one teammate of his
or coach that's sticking up for him go
name one you hear anything any coach
going he's actually a really good dude
name one Wow remember Randy Moss is
having his issues ton of people came to
bat for him have you heard one for
Antonio Brown no ever that says a lot of
time I mean your hon people you work
with the closest Wow
so you know he's an [ __ ] yeah but
he's the best football DBS hasn't played
hasn't played since last year and better
than I've al back home oh yeah yeah
shows up cut four passes in a touchdown
in the first quarter
Jesus beast no one can cover more what
is it just his speed everything this is
good busy in conversations not good he's
[ __ ] yeah what else yet there's a
quick funny one this guy who's busted
already wanted on meth charges looks
just like Walter White
oh wow no yeah well he does does does
that's impressive but you gotta watch
Breaking Bad I can't believe you don't
see it I'm watching uh watching True
Blood right now it's fine cool Breaking
Bad dude True Blood goes off the rails
Breaking Bad he's better after a while
True Blood just keeps coming
Breaking Bad I can't believe you have a
resistance I can't believe I was like
this was Game of Thrones I hate so long
for me to get and the soprano every
watch surprised yet I chose to do blood
over Sopranos I
can't get it I like vampires man I can't
take it
I really can't you got to do it there's
just no mystery and Breaking Bad from
yantras sells wife has cancer all right
it's a beauty it's an unbelievable I
heard I hear that dude I'll get around
to it give me another five years what
else we get that looks like [ __ ]
he died you know I stopped breaking by
to you and I thought it was amazing and
then after a certain episode I got it
right I just didn't like it I see
something great in that picture what you
have to know like a sponsor to ask you
just one more yeah this is a good news
Artie Lange seven months rehab sobriety
he's sober for some money looks good to
you right stand up - yeah he's great
let's go all you gotta do is fix his
nose either way - looks good
help me just fix that goes yeah how
about good for him man just a good
person good for him said it that's it
cool man good podcast buddy I'm an AC in
here dude I'm gonna get you a Antonio
Brown Jersey I'm gonna see if I can get
some Tennison three o'clock
oh you know you should do want you a
volley these nuts
what yeah Pete Sampras style suck my
dick I don't know what that even means
that's aggressive
Tampa come series with 27 to 28 Tampa
improv I'll be the two shows Friday - so
Saturday the campaign brother get your
tickets or die
Randy's gonna be a human this week out
in Houston Friday Saturday - shows
Friday - show Saturday Houston improv
death the squad Derek post in Tucson
with me and the next week mama I'm
coming home mama economy works downtown
Denver Thursday Friday Saturday and then
just when I sail Pittsburgh and Philly
in October those shows almost sold out t
fat K calm for take is my office water
and thing about food in Houston t fat
cake on t guitar Brian and myself I like
everything dude got a new tour I'm
announcing I think Wednesday you're up
all sorts of dates stay tuned Ronnie
Beck a background Europe
yeah bro dis the final kid all these
nuts in your mouth
we're out